more people are becoming sick from a
salmonella outbreak that promised that
promoted rather a massive egg recall the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention says at least 35 people
across nine states have been infected by
the bacteria hospitals treated 11
victims in a Werner is here with who may
be at risk and a good morning good
morning John a dozen more cases of
Salmonella trace to eggs have been
reported since the CDC first announced
the outbreak nearly a month ago the Food
and Drug Administration has linked the
outbreak to Rose acre farms in the
company's facility in North Carolina
last month the company voluntarily
recalled more than 206 million eggs due
to potential contamination the recalled
eggs were distributed between January
11th and April 12th two grocery chains
and restaurants in at least nine states
the FDA reported during an inspection of
Rosica farms beginning in March they
found more than a dozen rodents they
also say employees touched dirty
equipment and their bodies without
washing their hands in a statement Rose
acre farm says it has not only corrected
deficiencies at the farm but also taken
steps to ensure that the farm meets or
exceeds the standards of the FDA and
USDA now to see if the eggs you
purchased might be recalled you can
visit cBS This Morning Calm if it turns
out that you have recalled eggs the CDC
says don't eat them either throw them
away or you can return them for a refund
but a lot of serious health concerns for
people who are elderly children under
age 5 and people with weakened immune
systems are really the people who are at
risk here more than people hitting the
refrigerator right other people can get
really sick but I think it works my
channel yeah